[Music]
ever feel like you're the last to know
about something well Bill and Hillary
Clinton might make you feel better about
that they are literally the only two
people in the world who don't yet
realize they're not as popular as they
once were the former president and first
lady just launched a national speaking
tour because 250 million dollars is not
enough and yet sales have been
lackluster to put it charitably New York
Times columnist Maureen Dowd described
thousands of arena seats being covered
up in Toronto due to poor sales ticket
prices should begin in the hundreds of
dollars fell to single digits by the end
because nobody wanted to buy him the
market at work is America finally
mercifully getting over the Clintons
author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight
to assess mark before we assess what's
obvious
their time is over the deeper question
is why don't they know that and what is
this speaking tour about well I would
have thought that if you didn't know
before looking out it and actually
Maureen Dowd overestimated the number of
seats it was actually 80 the 83.4% empty
the arena in Toronto the Scotiabank
83.4% empty I believe actually the last
time I guest-hosted for you the audience
was suddenly 83.4% empty so these things
can happen when you're the private
numbers that's not true when when you're
the president a dad and a putative next
president it's a great Frank Sinatra
line you should always listen very
carefully when the public is telling you
goodbye and that's what the 16.6%
seating capacity in Toronto was telling
the Clintons but I wonder why I mean
it's not surprising either and I have to
say in their defense they've played this
out a lot longer than I ever thought
they possibly could I mean it's been
over 25 years now I've never found them
very impressive but they
managed to get incredibly rich hundreds
of millions of dollars rich and stay
famous all this time so they've had a
long run considering where they started
but why do they feel the need to do this
that's what baffles me no it's it makes
an interesting contrast with what's
going on
in the Rotunda right now because you can
say what you like about the first
President Bush but his post-presidency
was a model of a dignified post
political life which is why he's getting
that which is one reason he's getting
the send-off he's getting by contrast I
think it's a Tina Brown line where she
said she said something like he has a
about Bill Clinton he has a heat-seeking
glamor that lives in the a permanent
hyper present tense and dares you to
join in there and I think that in her
own way she action she she actually
understood that these they're on a
perpetual hamster wheel and and for the
last few years they they would get
raking in big bucks from a niche market
lay about Saudi princes and Kazakh
oligarchs and all these other sleazy
figures who were willing to give the
millions of dollars because they thought
they were going to be back in the White
House now they can't get people to give
them in Toronto they couldn't get people
to give them ten bucks
that's what ticket price will and that's
$10 Canadian which thanks to Justin
Trudeau is about a buck a buck seventy
nine American right now so the
difference between what a Saudi prince
is prepared to pay and and what an
average ordinary member of the public in
Toronto is prepared to pay tells you of
what what has happened to the Clintons
in the real world so very quickly I'm
just speculating here but since you know
everything I'm just gonna run this by
you because maybe you know the answer
those eight or nine guys who dismembered
khashoggi how many were donors to the
Clinton Foundation do you know off the
top of your head well the the clever
thing about them is that warring
factions in the House of Saud were all
big darkness to the Clinton Foundation
I'm not saying you know
I don't say there's different princes
but they were they were all trying to
buy off the Clinton Foundation in the
good old days
prices slices / to prices / to clear on
Clinton Foundation speeches now I've
noticed works done always so refreshing
to see you thank you thanks a lot Tucker